We are trying to give zero for zero.
Joe Rode a
fascinating thing to transmit,
kind once said about a mushroom trip.
He asked a mushroom,
how could he possibly,
how could anyone possibly save the path
that humans are on?
And they said very simply and very
easily.
Each parent,
each,
each couple should reproduce.
Once you know two people,
they have one kid.
Everybody relaxes the whole the
resources.
Relax everything.
Relax.
It's like there's plenty of fucking
people.
Okay.
There is zero worry that people are
going to go extinct.
But then the problem is how do you go to
those people?
Like those crazy people that were on
that TV show that had 19 children,
many of those people.
First of all,
what is she,
what is she in labor for like three
seconds.
I mean,
what,
what?
Does he actually have sex with her or
does he just jerk off into the abyss?
Like how,
how,
how are those babies actually
fertilized?
Um,
that,
that woman,
how could you tell that woman she can't
do that.
I mean,
I think it's a freak show.
I think it's,
I think resources wise,
like I have three kids,
it's hard,
it's hard to give them all the time that
they deserve,
you know,
and me and my wife had discussed that
when it comes to the possibility of
having more children,
I said I think we should really
concentrate on raising the ones we have.
Like they're fun and it's great and I,
they needed a lot of time,
like children need a lot of time and I
enjoy giving them that time.
But I think that if you have another kid
around,
everyone gets a little bit less time and
I think in that getting less time,
there's some benefits to independence
aspect of it as long as there's love and
there's comfort.
But I also think you can teach kids a
lot of shit,
you know,
and you could teach them a lot,
especially if you really are into it and
you concentrate on it and you read a lot
of books on it,
which I'm really involved in the idea of
raising kids.
I'm raising little human beings.
So the conversations that I have with
them are all geared towards that.
Like it's geared towards enlightening
them is to the world and it sort of
guiding them is how to,
how to treat people,
how to be nice to be,
but it'd be nice to your sister or like,
Be Nice to have to pee,
don't,
don't get angry at things for no reason.
Look at it this way instead of that way.
And I think that,
you know,
you ain't gonna miss a lot of that when
you have 15,
16 kids,
you're going to like,
do you guys just shut the fuck up,
shut the fuck up organized teams.
You,
you're responsible for your little
brother,
you are,
you're responsible for.
And that's what those people did.
Those people have like every kid has a
chore and every kid,
that's how you're raised zombies.
I mean these kids,
they're not going to know what the fuck
is going on in the world.
Like they're going to need someone to
help them every day is spent doing tasks
and,
and your life is basically religion,
homeschooling and these tasks.
That's those kids.
That's the 19 people.
What are they?
The duggins,
what they call a CV.
I find that,
I mean,
I don't think you could tell those
people not to do that.
I think this is America and America has
got it's faults,
but,
but think about it,
they only neutralized like eight gay
couples neutralized when you went.
I mean like those kids,
you average it out,
like you got eight gay couples
who don't have any kids or adopt a kid
which takes it out of the pool and
you're,
you know,
mathematically you can have outliers
like that because there are lots of
people like me who don't have kids,
you know,
and just,
I mean,
I think the way to do it is to remove
the stigma around not having kids and to
encourage 'em to n w what Helen,
Sarah hrdy calls aloe parenting.
And this gets back to the hunter
gatherer thing.
Like kids are raised by everybody.
You know,
they say,
you know,
two parents are better than one.
Yeah,
that's true.
But you know what?
Five parents are better than two takes
pressure off you,
right?
Because you get frustrated,
you get tired,
you know,
their mother gets tired and it also,
it's enriching for the adult.
I love being around kids for a couple
hours.
Yeah,
no,
I know fully.
You know,
we had a party at my house,
had the day and there was a gang for
Halloween.
There was a Halloween party and there
was a gang of kids over and it was fun.
It was fun talking to other people's
little kids and you know,
seeing other different and how they
behave different,
have different ideas about stuff and you
know,
there's nothing wrong with that.
This is the family,
the 19 folks that live at home together.
Nice House stuff for 19 guy has been
making some good bank be paying for all
those kids.
Maybe just loves to fuck all this
religion stuff.
It's just to keep them all around.
Just love sending it in.
Nineteen kids seems a little excessive,
but again,
he's anal not for really religious
people.
I think it's in the Bible.
Do you know that?
That was Sarah Palin.
She said that Sarah Palin had a
conversation with a librarian and was
Cilla Alaska,
where she said that on the Internet
there was a photograph of,
of human footprint inside of dinosaur
footprint,
and the woman,
like the woman like talked about this
and Sarah Palin was running for
president or vice president,
whatever,
and she was like,
what?
Pause the
fuck.
Like this is a woman that got a
heartbeat away from being the president.
And she thought she thought that
dinosaurs and humans walk together and
then you see people who are intelligent
get that pill that down.
Brian claim dinosaurs of people
coexisted because they say they're about
the librarian.
I'm whatever.
I think that,
um,
uh,
what's the other one?
I'm not Sarah Palin.
Michele Bachman.
Michele Bachmann's worse.
Well,
her husband's gay rights is gay,
is gay as gay,
as gay as the day is beautiful and long
and flowers smell pretty and butterflies
are beautiful.
That guy's gay and allegedly he can't
suck enough dick.
There's no way.
If you could just give him a free pass,
if you ever got that guy liquored up and
put a heart on in front of him,
he would jump on it like Greg Louganis
off the top peer swan dive on that.
His head would be spinning out of a gain
or he'd still get some tongue on the
chef.
He would automatically starts salivating
to the point where it was like a
waterfall coming out of his mouth,
which is pouring down shirts just so
alive.
A Long Street.
No where the pool started and the saliva
for Dick coming out.
Okay.
Yeah.
It would literally be like a saliva
waterfall and when,
when when people have a backyard and
they have those really like,
like fancy little rock formations where
the water comes down into their pool.
Fancy schmancy.
That was his mouth.
Yeah.
If he.
He would say to a young man,
do you want to go in the hot tub with
me?
And the guy would go,
okay,
they'd get in the hot tub and the guy
would go,
there's no water in here.
And he'd go,
just wet
cock,
warm and gooey.
It's comes out 96 degrees.
I'd let them blow me if I knew that I
could take down Michelle Bachmann
particular down.
From what though?
Just because she will be an elected
leader.
Joe,
you really feel that?
I know.
So look,
you just have to see who fox news is
trotting out and she is one of the first
pundits they go to for comments on shit.
She is introducing legislation in
Congress right now that is actually
being enacted.
So what's the stopper?
Me,
I will suck her husband's Dick and
release it on the.
On the Internet.
I'll take the hit.